[Musik]
leute ich muss ganz ehrlich gestehen ich
verstehe es nicht ganz ganz große story
die leute die mein kanadischer folgen
wissen dass ich sehr oft videos mit
anderen mache und ich liebe das videos
mehr an zu machen und ich weiß wenn ich
gar nicht was ich machen soll wenn ich
allein in seinem video ist zwar mein
bruder max und seine freundin jahre mit
denen ich eigentlich immer videos mache
vor lange weg und ich sagte also alleine
und scheiße was mache ich jetzt dann bin
ich aber hat diese hilfsaktion gekommen
und habe davon einige gemacht und dachte
mir also okay gut jetzt ist bestimmt
auch gut es reicht jetzt eigentlich oder
scheinbar nicht ich weiß nicht wann ich
das letzte mal so viel bekommen von
leuten die gesagt haben machen bitte das
und das video reagiert darauf und da
drauf und und ich muss sagen es macht
richtig bock diese videos zu machen und
wenn ihr auch bock drauf habt dann bin
ich der letzte der nein sagt hör nicht
vorbei ich doch nicht wahr
das video ist es heute anfangen geht auf
sehr vielen von euch zurück und auf luca
aber nicht youtube luca sondern ein
analoger aus der uni von max der hat mir
auch gesagt macht dieses video unbedingt
jetzt mache ich und zwar geht es um
nichts geringeres als frau tourismus
anders muss zwanghaft seinen unterleib
breiten ganz kurz auf leute bevor wir
statten checkt unbedingt meinen
instagram account aus der heißt so hilft
nämlich ganz spezielle aktionen laufen
jede person nämlich auf instagram
abonniert erhält ihr wahlweise drei
operationen oder einmal herr langohr
genug aber fangen wir an wir haben hier
unseren screenshot bei video 00 eine
welt in der viele welten platz haben
okay okay da haben wir einen ganz so
junge mann ist das outfit auf jeden fall
[Musik]
du musst das leben und überleben
ich bin ehrlich gesagt unentschieden was
ich selbst aber finde ist es sein outfit
was aus den 1960 er jahren kommt oder
ist es die tatsache dass er seinen
unterleib an einem baum reibt als
während fucking wildschwein oder es ist
die tatsache dass er danach einen baum
eine gewissermaßen große pflanze
anspricht und sich bei ihr dafür bedankt
dass er gerade eben seinen unterleib an
ihr gerieben hat muss loswurde
[Musik]
warum haben diese hilft mir videos immer
so ein raver also müsst ihr also raid 1
raid ist englisch für vergewaltigung
ungefähr gerade auch jedes video was ich
mir angeschaut von hilfe hat sohn lebt
bei dieser art operation was der chirurg
der die irgendwie etwas zwingen wollte
weil privat tatsache dass in als
prinzessin vertreter man auch ein
kleines kind auf dem spielplatz zu geht
bei diesem video haben sich dann gedacht
habe weisst was lasst einfach komplett
drauf scheißen wir machen das einfach
nicht mal unterschwellig sondern wir
sagen einfach einem mann er soll sich an
der passanten bereiten
geht's noch
das finde ich gut heute endlich mal ein
mann der sich nicht von seinem traum
abhalten lässt er geht durch den park
reibt sich an einer wildfremden frau die
voll scheiße von ihr beschwert sich
darüber aber er lässt sich nicht
aufhalten der geht direkt weiter und
reibt sich am nächsten baum anders
anders scheint unter einer extremen form
von frau tourismus zu leiten und
sätzlich versteht man unter futurismus
das reiben des unterleibs an menschen
oder gegenständen der grat zwischen
harmlosem reiben und sexueller
belästigung ist allerdings sehr schmal
das stimmt das hängt nämlich davon haben
wie schnell man s macht bis zu einer
geschwindigkeit von einmal reiben pro
sekunde ist es doch okay als ist keine
sexuelle belästigung leute leben in der
freien gesellschaft das musst du
aushalten sobald man aber über einmal
reifen pro sekunde hinaus geht also zum
beispiel so in richtung rammeln also ja
ich mache das nicht vor ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen anders ist von der
bewegungsgeschwindigkeit hier auf jeden
fall noch im legalen rahmen und die
werte dame an der stelle können wir
direkt ifri sollten und anders muss
unbedingt aufpassen sonst kann er sich
ganz schnell in schwierigkeiten bringen
kleine woanders lebt zu hause bei seiner
mutter dorothea seit dem tod seines
vaters haben die beiden ein ganz
spezielles verhältnis deutlich mehr
leute das klingt nicht gut von anders
heimlich im drang hat die 50-jährige
allerdings keine ahnung was eigentlich
los in den park zu gehen und uns
zusammen einen wildfremden menschen zu
reiben
an der stelle muss ich sagen anders
du hast wieder vollkommen recht mehr als
30 sekunden sollte man am tag nicht mit
seiner familie verbringen
dutchbat touch das ist wirklich nicht
gut auf leute anziehen verkürzt dich ja
das sieht nach einer sehr ungesunden
mutter sohn beziehung aus anders sollte
seine sexuellen erfahrungen mit
gleichaltrigen natürlich alter coco wie
die boxershorts sieht alter fordert
dessen weiter auf gegenstände und
freunde aus halo auf zureden hallo herr
lehmann wort darüber wie weit oben
diese box erschoss ist einfach gerade
kastriert werden
du hast dich vergessen haben mir zu
reiben
kurz darauf anders steht ständig unter
druck seinem fatalen zwang nachgehen zu
müssen
besonders ja und wenn wir es die man da
sieht stein was anders hier macht würde
man zwar allgemein als sexuelle
belästigung bezeichnet strafbar ist es
aber nicht ohne weiteres teppich leute
ich muss ganz kurz vor die tür
einkaufen im park das liegt daran dass
es bei uns in deutschland keinen
paragrafen gibt der sexuelle belästigung
für sich genommen unter strafe stellt im
so etwas passiert der sollte daher erst
einmal einfach weitergeht sagte ich ja
bis zu einer reibung pro sekunde ist das
komplett legal anders ist völlig
überfordert mit seinem zwang sich zu
reiben
sein bester freund nils weiß davon
nichts
[Musik]
was ist das für ein seltsamer schnitt
typ hat gerade schwere probleme und wird
von seiner mutter zu hause belästigt
reibt sich an wildfremde menschen und er
als sein bester kumpel hat nichts
besseres tun als klimmzüge machen am
parc du wirst du siehst du durch den
winter was irgendwie geist gesehen oder
nein er hat sich grad nur an diversen
passanten gerieben alles gut wir müssen
ja irgendwie mädchen wir sollen das
macht mich ein bisschen entspannt du
wirst immer so aufgeteilt
denn weder gelang bin ich schon auf 30
wie du jetzt richtig man muss man
unterscheiden zwischen aufreißen und
dran reiben was hältst du von der idee
wenn wir einfach mal in richtung
jugendzentrum laufen und mädchen das da
sind doch immer angst haben teile weil
die nicht werden kann ganz ehrlich nie
ist so lang habe ich die schnauze voll
okay ich glaube du weißt es mit den über
jedes du redest mich anders ok anders
hat sich schatten mehr mädchen gerieben
als jemals in deinem lebens sehen wirst
hast lass das mal lieber mit dem letzten
mal finde ich besser
lasst uns mal losgehen
die gaal ist froh dass zum jugendzentrum
gehen
gabriels bob grow ganz kurz ich fühle
mich eben noch an den shop vertreiben
kein ding braucht noch ruhig dagegen
laufen es aber ganz anders aus das war
so als hättest du dir das ist nicht so
ein scheiß nicht ganz normal gegen die
laufen kommt zwar nicht so zwei stunden
später mutter dorothea konzentriert sich
nur noch auf anders dass sie ihn damit
völlig erdrückt merkt die 50 jährige
nicht
[Musik]
aber ganz groß hier was macht diese hand
da unten
was man halt so macht wir haben kicker
gespielt und da gespielt weist er als
ich so einfach wie du da habe ich mit
papa button roll getanzt rock'n'roll
davon habe ich noch nicht gehört haben
ja auch nicht alle mütter und söhne so
ein tolles verhältnis wie am nächsten
tag laura will unbedingt die wette mit
nils gewinnen mit anders mutter dorothea
hat die 17 jährige allerdings nicht
gerechnet
die arme weil es nicht worauf sie sich
einlässt seine freundin
[Musik]
mädchen die erste matchball für dich
euro
sie betritt hier trotz ernst seine
freundin seit gestern kann ich nicht
mehr noch nicht so groß sein
na ja wahr geworden war hat mama wird
sonst kurz allein lassen da ich das ihr
hier bei den anfangs hier um zu kämpfen
mach deine hausaufgaben ein die wird
sich nur ein ding gerieben ok thema was
jetzt neu
[Musik]
darauf hat die schon seit gestern
nachmittag das sind die epischen dinge
im leben wenn endlich der moment
eintritt auf dem man seit gestern
nachmittag gewartet hat das sieht es
ausgehalten hat wahnsinnig ist aber ganz
schön ran
laura ich glaube es am besten wenn du
jetzt gehst die wir können uns ja später
im jugendzentrum sind dann das nachher
ich bei mir schon ich bin nämlich auch
auf autos
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sie steht auch outdoor sex dann ist doch
alles gut werde man sich jetzt nicht
ganz verstanden habe ist sie sagt anders
geht ganz schön ran und sie kennen sich
seit einem tag und danach lag die so
jung dass x outdoor sex haben nachher
aber im bett körperkontakt also auf dem
parkplatz vom lidl mit nicht okay aber
im bett das war's dann wieder komplett
und leute sowie mal nach einem richtig
fetten deftigen essen kaffee braucht um
klar zu kommen habe ich euch jetzt nach
dieser inzestuösen seltsamen
veranstaltung noch ein normales video
verlinkt in dem garantiert keine
seltsamen sachen was ihr leut und zwar
eine neue folge von was das geht
zusammen mit mir beziehungsweise noch
nicht ganz gibt schon seit zwei wochen
aber dann trete ich auf der gamescom und
gegen einen professionellen sports
profil fifa in verschiedenen challenges
an chips ab und bitte bleiben normale
leute